on the Rubin report each week we try not
to get too caught up in the minutiae of
what's going on each day in the news
while paying attention to current events
is obviously important there's so much
happening all of the time and staying on
top of every single news story can be
overwhelming and exhausting the really
important but less sexy issues like
infrastructure and education often get
overlooked or left behind instead I try
to focus our conversations on the
philosophical underpinnings that leave
my guests to their conclusions rather
than discussing every specific
occurrence that happened that very day
real conversations and clear thinking
are a long game and it's often more
important to understand why people think
a certain way than how they think about
a particular issue
unfortunately this technique is totally
lost on almost everyone these days which
is why instead we bounced from one daily
outrage to the next in an election year
particularly this election year this
concept of bouncing from one outrage to
the next has reached a whole new level
of insanity before you even have a
minute to process what the candidates
actually said media on both sides is
telling you how outraged you should be
and which hashtag you should use to
voice your outrage with every quote
statement and comment is endlessly
clipped and analyzed to the point that
you can barely figure out what was
originally said candidates subtweet each
other to see who can come up with the
best insult and go on late-night talk
shows to see who can get the most fake
laughs the sideshow has become the main
show and we've all got a front row seat
recently I said I was gonna support
Libertarian candidate Gary Johnson to
see if we could help get him to 15% in
the national polls which would have
qualified him for the presidential
debates although I explained that Gary
isn't even a great candidate nor of
particularly good libertarian at the
very least we needed more voices to be
heard on the debate stage than what the
Democrats and Republicans have managed
to throw at us my hope was that if we
could just get someone else to join
Trump and Hillary for even 1/2
bait that we could spark some new ideas
in people which might make our political
discourse a little saner unfortunately
Gary didn't make it into the debate and
much of the blame is on Gary himself in
addition to a generally uninspiring
campaign in a year when a huge
percentage of Americans would have
seriously given a third party a real
look Gary has had a series of gaffes
making me even question my initial
support for him just Google Gary Johnson
Aleppo or Gary Johnson tongue or Gary
Johnson illegal immigration while we
failed to get another candidate into the
debates this time around it's my hope
that no matter who wins this election by
2020 we'll finally get ourselves out of
this stifling two-party gridlock it will
be incredibly hard work to make this a
reality but it starts by starving both
parties of what they craved most which
of course is money until we get around
to putting them on their cash diet the
least we can do is listen to new and
interesting voices who are trying to cut
through the political clutter my guest
this week is futurist and journalist
Zoltan Istvan who is running for the
President on the newly-formed
transhumanist party the goal of the
party which Zoltan himself created is to
put science health and technology at the
forefront of American politics
well I somehow doubt that 2016 is gonna
be zoltan's year I think the issues that
he's talking about like artificial
intelligence designer babies and chip
implants are things that will be shaping
the future of our society regardless of
who's in office whether it's President
Clinton or President Trump technology is
coming at us faster than ever and we
should be thinking about the moral and
ethical consequences of a world changing
at Lightspeed you never know maybe
discussing all this stuff now will buy
us an extra year or two before the
robots take over though I for one will
gladly welcome our new robot overlords
you